>> Sean: AS WE SHOWED YOU
LAST NIGHT DEMOCRATS RADICAL
EXTREMISM HIT A NEW LEVEL
WHEN 2020 HOPEFUL BERNIE
SANDERS MADE THE SHOCKING
ADMISSIONS OH, YEAH, FELONS,
INCLUDING THE TSARNAEV
BROTHERS, PEDOPHILES,
MURDERERS SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO VOTE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN
RESPONDED TO THESE
OUTRAGEOUS COMMENTS CALLING
IT DEEPLY OFFENSIVE AND SOME
MORE EMBARRASSING COMMENTS
FROM SANDERS NOW
RESURFACING.
LOOK AT THIS 1971 SANDERS
HARSHLY CRITICIZED GET THIS.
MILLIONAIRE SENATORS.
HE SAID THEY ARE IMMORAL.
HE IS A MILLIONAIRE SENATOR.
WHY WE SAY THAT ABOUT
HIMSELF?
I WONDER IF BERNIE STANDS BY
THAT TODAY?
NOW SANDERS WILL SOON HAVE
MORE COMPANY IN THE ALREADY
CROWDED 2020 RACE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, HOURS
AWAY FROM CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE BIDEN EXPECTED TO THROW
HIS HAT INTO THE RING.
THE FORMER V.P. IS ALREADY
FACING A POSSIBLE SET BACK.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES OBAMA,
WHO HE SERVED UNDER FOR
EIGHT YEARS WON'T ENDORSE
HIM OR ANY 2020 CANDIDATE
EARLY IN THE RACE.
A LOT OF CONFIDENCE NEW,
JOE.
JOINING US NOW SENIOR
ADVISOR FOR DONALD J. TRUMP
FOR PRESIDENT THAT WOULD BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DAUGHTER-IN-LAW LARA TRUMP.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> I'M GREAT.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE BEEN BUSY.
>> OF COURSE WE HAVE ALL
BEEN BUSY, SEAN.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE A
PREFERENCE.
I THINK BIDEN WOULD BE
PERFECT.
BIDEN WON'T HAVE TO ANSWER
BY THE TIME 2020 COMES
AROUND EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED UNDER THEIR WATCH
HE IS GOING TO ANSWER FOR
THEIR CRAPPY ECONOMY AND
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS A MILLION MORE
ON POVERTY.
QUESTION ARE YOU BETTER OFF
THAN YOU WERE FOUR YEARS
AGO.
SIMPLE.
>> LISTEN, IT DOESN'T
MATTER, SEAN, WHO THIS
PRESIDENT IS RUNNING
AGAINST.
I ALWAYS SAY THAT I THINK HE
IS GOING TO WIN EASILY.
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S LET JOE
BIDEN GET IN THE RACE.
HE HAS BEEN SAYING FOR
MONTHS NOW THAT HE IS GOING
TO GET IN THE RACE IT HASN'T
HAPPENED YET.
WE WILL SEE TOMORROW IF IT
HAPPENS.
BUT, HE CERTAINLY RIGHT NOW
SEEMS TO LOOK THE MOST SANE
OUT OF THE CANDIDATES THAT
WE HAVE SEEN OF THE 20
CANDIDATES NOW THAT WE HAVE
SEEN THROW THEIR HAT IN THE
RING FOR 2020.
THAT'S FOR SURE AND THAT'S
SAYING A LOT.
>> Sean: LISTEN, HE STILL
HAS TO DEFEND THE THINGS WE
ARE GOING TO LEARN ABOUT
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR USED
THE WORD SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Sean: STEPHON HALPER WAS
RECRUITED TO TALK TO
PAPADOPOULOS.
DIRTY DOSSIER THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" WAS SAYING THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A DISINFORMATION
PROPAGANDA THING HILLARY
BOUGHT AND USED TO INFLUENCE
THE CAMPAIGN BACK DOOR THE
PRESIDENT'S ELECTION.
>> I THINK THERE IS A LOT
THAT THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
AND OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER TO
WHEN IT COMES TO ALL THE
BACKGROUND ON THIS.
AND HOPEFULLY FOR THE GOOD
OF OUR COUNTRY WE REALLY
FIND OUT HOW THIS ALL
STARTED AND WE GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
IT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
THAT THERE WAS SPYING ON OUR
CAMPAIGN IN 2016.
BUT, LISTEN, AGAIN, AT THE
END OF THE DAY, IF JOE BIDEN
GETS IN THE RACE LET'S
SEASON SEE IF HE MAKES IT
THE NUMBER OF CANDIDATES
THAT ARE SO RADICALLY FAR
LEFT NOW IN THIS FIELD IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
SO I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE JOE
BIDEN DOESN'T STAND A
CHANCE.
MAYBE THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY SO FAR OUTSIDE OF
THE NORM WHICH IS CRAZY TO
ME I DON'T THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL GET
BEHIND SOMEBODY LIKE THIS.
>> Sean: DON'T SUPPORT 70%
TAX RATE FOR INDIVIDUALS.
90% TAX RATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
NO OIL NO, GAS NO.
--
>> NO AIRPLANES, NO COWS.
>> Sean: I LIKE COWS.
I LOVE THEM.
SOFT NOSES AND EVERYTHING.
>> ALL THIS STUFF IS SO
CRAZY AND THEN YOU HAVE AS
YOU WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS SUGGESTING
THAT SOMEONE WOULD USE AN
EVENT THAT IS SUCH A
TRADITION IN AMERICA LIKE
THE BOSTON MARATHON TO AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAIM AND
MURDER SCORES OF PEOPLE,
INCLUDING CHILDREN, SEAN,
AND THESE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD
BE ALLOTTED A RIGHT TO VOTE?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
IT'S CRAZY THAT WE ARE EVEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
SO I HAVE HAD -- I REMEMBER
ONE DAY BEING MAD AT THE
PRESIDENT.
THE DAY HE BECOMES
MAKES THE COMMENT LET BY
GONES BE BY GONES.
LEAVE HILLARY ALONE.
OKAY.
WE HEAR HILLARY TODAY.
I THOUGHT THEN IT WAS A
MISTAKE AND I DON'T THINK IS
HE THINKING THAT ANYMORE.
YOU SEE THE FBI
INVESTIGATION.
NUNES REPORT HOUSE INTEL.
NOW MUELLER, NO COLLUSION,
NO OBSTRUCTION.
AND STILL THEY CANNOT
CONTROL THEMSELVES.
MEDIA OR DEMOCRATS.
THAT, TO ME, HELPS YOU.
>> OH, OF COURSE IT HELPS
US.
I MEAN, EVERYBODY ON THE
LEFT IS SO UNHINGED THAT
THERE WASN'T ANYTHING IN THE
MUELLER REPORT.
NOW IT'S FINALLY OUT.
NOW WE CAN FINALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT IT AND, AGAIN, AS WE
ALL SAID FROM THE BEGINNING,
NO COLLUSION, THERE IS
NOTHING THAT THIS PRESIDENT
HAS DONE WRONG.
BUT LOOK AT ALL HE HAS
ACCOMPLISHED, SEAN.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE TRIED EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT HE DID SOMETHING WRONG.
OUR CAMPAIGN DID SOMETHING
WRONG.
THEY FIGHT HIM EVERY DAY.
RESIST HIM EVERY DAY.
OBSTRUCT WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
ALL THE TIME.
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW UNDER
THIS PRESIDENT IS THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL THAN IT HAS BEEN
IN DECADES.
>> Sean: WE HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT COMING UP AFTER
THE SHOW -- LATER IN THE
SHOW NOT AFTER THE SHOW.
>> I THOUGHT IT'S GOING TO
BE THAT I'M PREGNANT.
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW IF I
COULD SAY THAT.  THAT'S THE
OTHER BIG NEWS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: DO YOU KNOW YET BOY
OR GIRL?
>> YOUR LITTLE BOY IS SO BIG
AND REALLY HANDSOME.
>> HE IS GREAT.
HE WILL BE A GREAT BIG
BROTHER WHATEVER IT IS.
>> Sean: SHOULD WE TAKE THAT
CONGRATULATIONS, HAPPY AND
HEALTHY IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS INCREDIBLE
CAPACITY TO COMPARTMENTIZE
EVEN THOUGH IS HE FIGHTING
AND DEALING TWO PLUS YEARS
FOR THIS.
TO FIGHT FOR ALL THE THINGS
HE PROMISED.
ONE THING THAT A POLITICIAN
USUALLY DOESN'T DO IS KEEP
THEIR PROMISES.
THE BORDER.
YOU NAME THE ISSUE, JUSTICES
THAT HE APPOINTS.
THE BIGGEST TAX CUTS ENDING
REGULATION.
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE STILL
FIGHTING TO GET RID OF ALL
OF OBAMACARE.
>> SINCE OUR RALLIES WE HAVE
HAD SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THE CAMPAIGN IN 2015
EVEN, PROMISES MADE,
PROMISES KEPT.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS THAT NOT THE
ALL TALK, NO ACTION
POLITICIANS OF THE PAST.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT THAT HAS
DELIVERED ON EVERY SINGLE
PROMISE HE MADE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE RUNNING
ON IN 2020.
>> Sean: WAS THIS ALL HARD
FOR YOU, THE FAMILY, BEHIND
THE SCENES?
THE TWO YEARS NONSTOP
WITCH-HUNT?
>> IT NEVER FEELS GOOD WHEN
PEOPLE SUGGEST THAT YOU DID
SOMETHING WRONG AND YOU KNOW
YOU DIDN'T.
AND FOR THE PRESIDENT FOR
EVERYONE THAT WORKED ON THIS
CAMPAIGN.
WE'LL WORKED OUR HEARTS OUT
ON THIS CAMPAIGN.
I FEEL SO HONORED TO HAVE
DONE IT.
>> Sean: YOU WERE A BIG PART
OF IT.
>> OF COURSE IT DOESN'T FEEL
GOOD.
WE ALL KNEW THE TRUTH WOULD
COME OUT ONE DAY.
SADLY, YOU STILL HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO FIND
SOMETHING WRONG THAT ANY OF
US DID.
THEY WON'T FIND IT THEY CAN
KEEP LOOKING.
>> Sean: IF HE CURED CANCER
AND GAVE EVERY AMERICAN
$5 MILLION AND ADOPT YOU HAD